Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Dominic Sandbrook, and my sidekick, or my puppet master as he calls himself, Tom Holland. Tom, hello. Hello. Happy New Year. Happy New Year. Now, we are not yet in the New Year. We're anticipating the New Year.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及深受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），旁边是我的搭档，或者像他自己说的那样，我的幕后操纵者汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）。汤姆，你好。你好。新年快乐。新年快乐。不过，我们现在还没到新年。我们在期待新年。
So, we are very exercised aren't we about the b word the word that's been on everybody's lips for the last five years or so brexit and we don't know what's going to happen which is very exciting because our listeners will know you'll listen you'll know when you're listening to this but we don't know whether there'll be a deal whether britain will have forged manfully into its new future or whether we'll be um you know blocked up with lorries on the roads and disaster and all the rest of it um so there's an element of sort of jeopardy isn't there tom very exciting very very exciting indeed um and i think it's been heroic of us so far in the episodes we've done barely to mention brexit because i guess in a way um the arguments about
所以，我们现在对那个以“B”开头的词——过去五左右一直挂在每个人嘴边的词，也就是“脱欧”（Brexit）——感到非常兴奋，对吧？而且我们不知道会发生什么，这非常令人激动。因为我们的听众在收听的时候会知道结果，但我们并不知道是否会达成协议，英国是会雄心勃勃地开辟其新未来，还是会像传言那样道路上挤满卡车、陷入灾难等等。所以这里面有一种不确定性，对吧，汤姆？非常激动人心，确实非常非常激动人心。而且我认为，在我们迄今为止录制的节目中，几乎完全不提脱欧，这本身就很了不起，因为我想在某种程度上，关于
it whether you are in in favor of leaving or remaining, was always about history. Yeah, you're right. They have always been about history. So that is what we thought we might focus on today, is the comparisons that people have made in the debates over the past few years between the Brexit that we're going through now and previous examples of Brexit. Well, before we do that, we should quickly say, before you all turn off, we are not going to have any degree of argument about or discussion about whether Brexit was a good thing or a bad thing or why we did it or anything like that, are we?
它的争论——无论是赞成离开还是留欧——一直都关乎历史。是的，你说得对。它们一直都关乎历史。所以这正是我们今天想要聚焦的重点，也就是人们在过去几年的辩论中，将我们现在正在经历的脱欧与以往的脱欧案例进行的对比。好吧，在我们这样做之前，我们应该快速说明一下——在你们全都关掉节目之前——我们绝不会对脱欧是件好事还是坏事、我们为什么要这样做等类似问题展开任何程度的争论或讨论，对吧？
We're going to steer well clear of that and we're going to wear our historian's hats very firmly. I actually suspect we don't really disagree about Brexit, so it wouldn't even be a very interesting podcast anyway. However, we're going to talk about all these fascinating historical comparisons. And do you want to go first, Tom? I think you've got a colossal list of possible parallels. Yes, so I've drawn up what I think of the top 10 comparisons that people have made. Top 10 Brexits. Top ten Brexits. Over the centuries, and not just the centuries, over the millennia, because the very first Brexit is the drowning of Doggerland beneath the tsunami,
我们会远远避开这些话题，并且非常坚定地戴上我们的历史学家帽子。其实我猜我们对脱欧并没有什么实质性的分歧，所以无论如何这也成不了一个很有趣的播客。不过，我们要谈论的是所有这些迷人的历史对比。汤姆，你想先来吗？我想你列出了一份庞大的潜在相似之处清单。是的，所以我整理了我认为人们做出的前十大对比。十大脱欧事件。历史上的十大脱欧事件。跨越了几个世纪，不仅仅是几个世纪，而是几千年，因为第一次脱欧其实是海啸导致的道格兰（Doggerland）陆沉。
which happened 8,200 years ago. And Doggerland, of course, was, you know, Britain was originally attached to the continent with the ending of the Ice Age. Enorm enormous amounts of ice gets released into the sea. So the sea levels rise. And so this is the results in the North Sea. And there seems to have been a particular kind of disaster when there were kind of landslips by Norway. Great tsunami burst across and leaves Britain an island. And I guess that that is a fairly fundamental event because the fact that Britain is an island means that geography kind
发生在大约8200年前。道格兰，当然，你知道的，随着冰河时代的结束，英国最初是与欧洲大陆相连的。巨量的冰融化并流入海洋。于是海平面上升。这就导致了北海的形成。当时似乎发生了一种特殊灾难，挪威发生了某种山体滑坡。巨大的海啸席卷而过，将英国变成了一个岛屿。我想这是一个相当根本的事件，因为英国是一个岛屿这一事实意味着地理几乎决定了一切。
of underpins pretty much everything. Yeah. Are you one of these people who thinks that Britain's island nation identity is sort of fundamental to Britishness. Do you think that? Do you buy all that? I do think that the consciousness that we're separated from the mainland of Europe by that narrow strip of water is fairly fundamental. And I think that it generates exactly what we're talking about over this episode, which is this sense of push me, pull you. That we can't separate ourselves completely from the continent because we're too close to it. But equally, the impulse to do that is always there.
是的。你是不是那种认为英国作为岛国的身份对其“英国性”（Britishness）至关重要的人？你是这么想的吗？你相信这一切吗？我的确认为，通过那条狭窄的水域与欧洲大陆隔离开来的这种意识是相当根本的。而且我认为，这正是我们在本期节目中所讨论的内容的根源，也就是那种“推拉效应”（push me, pull you）。我们无法将自己与欧洲大陆完全割裂开来，因为我们离它太近了。但同样，想要这样做的冲动也一直存在。
And I think that that is why we've had all these Brexits. Can I ask you a question that shows my ignorance, just about the Doggerland question? When did human beings come to Britain? Well they came in waves um and then the ice ages come and crunch and crash everything up and they retreat and then they come back so there were people there who were detached from you know who were brexiteers involuntary brexiteers uh when well brexiteers to the extent that they exit britain yes yeah so that the there are kind of various hominids who who settle in britain and then retreat when the ice comes down and then they come back. But basically people have been continuously in Britain since the Mesolithic.
我认为这就是为什么我们会经历所有这些脱欧事件的原因。我可以问你一个暴露我无知的问题吗？就关于道格兰的问题。人类是什么时候来到英国的？嗯，他们是一波一波来的，然后冰河时代到来，把一切都粉碎和摧毁，他们撤退，然后又卷土重来。所以那里曾有人居住，他们与大陆分离，你知道的，他们是脱欧派，非自愿的脱欧派。呃，从脱欧的意义上来说，他们确实退出了英国，是的。所以有一类早期的人类在英国定居，然后在冰川南下时撤退，接着又回来了。但基本上，自中石器时代以来，英国就一直有人类连续居住。
So they arrived in Britain, the original inhabitants, because there was this land bridge. And interestingly, there was a kind of report early December that said that this Brexit, the Doggerland Brexit, may actually have been kind of slightly more after than we'd imagined. Because they're arguing that... Still in the single market. Yes, that there were kind of little islands that were left and that they only gradually sank. So it was a slightly more protracted Brexit. It wasn't quite as hard a Brexit as people had assumed.
所以他们来到英国，作为最初的居民，因为当时存在这座陆桥。有趣的是，12月初有一篇报道说，这次脱欧——道格兰脱欧——实际上可能比我们想象的要稍微延续得更久一些。因为他们的论点是……仍然留在单一市场里。是的，当时还残留着一些小岛，它们只是逐渐沉没。所以这是一次历时更长的脱欧。它并不像人们假设的那么彻底（硬脱欧）。
Anyway, well done. We've done Doggerland without making the obvious joke, so that's excellent. Well done. it wasn't quite as hard a brexit as as people had assumed anyway well done we've we've got we've done that we've got we've done doggerland without making the obvious joke so that's excellent well done and number two dominic what have you got for us so number two a few people uh brought this up so they asked about um rome so ollie simpson for example um raised said ac grayling had recently compared the eu with the roman Empire safety in numbers quality roads etc apparently is a bid to make us want to be part of it says Olly Simpson now yeah this is an interesting thing so this isn't really us leaving them so much as them leaving us right that the
不管怎样，干得好。我们谈完了道格兰，却没有开任何显而易见的玩笑，这太棒了。干得好。它并不像人们假设的那么彻底。不管怎样，干得好，我们讲完了道格兰，却没有开那个显而易见的玩笑，所以这太棒了，干得好。那么第二点，多米尼克，你给我们准备了什么？第二点，有一些人提到了这个，他们问到了罗马。比如奥利·辛普森（Ollie Simpson），他提出并说A·C·格雷林（AC Grayling）最近把欧盟比作罗马帝国——人多安全、道路优质等等，这显然是想让我们渴望成为其中一部分，奥利·辛普森说。现在，是的，这是一个有趣的事情与其说是我们离开他们，不如说是他们离开我们，对吧？
Romans well in in the sort of the sort of children's history book version of our past the Romans all leave Britain in what is it 410 Right about 410 they're meant to have left? Well, there are two iterations of this. Because we also have Andrew Sheldon comments, just Carusius. And Carusius was a Roman general who had control of the fleet in the Channel. And he essentially grabs hold of Britain and a chunk of Northern Gaul and declares his independence.
罗马人——嗯，在我们过去的某种儿童历史书版本中——罗马人在什么时候离开英国来着？公元410年？对，大约在410年，他们本应离开的？嗯，这有两种说法。因为我们还有安德鲁·谢尔顿（Andrew Sheldon）的评论，只提到了卡乌修斯（Carusius）。卡乌修斯是一位罗马将军，他控制了英吉利海峡的舰队。他基本上占领了英国和北高卢的一部分，并宣布独立。
And this has often been compared to Brexit. But actually, Crassus didn't want to leave the Roman Empire. He essentially wanted to be Roman Emperor himself. So I don't think that counts. So we're not including that. Actually, the Britons do leave. As far as we can tell, they do actively do a Brexit. No, the britons leave
这经常被拿来与脱欧作比较。但实际上，克拉苏（注：此处霍兰德口误将卡乌修斯说成克拉苏）并不是想离开罗马帝国。他基本上是想自己当罗马皇帝。所以我觉得这不算数。因此我们不把这算在内。事实上，不列颠人确实离开了。据我们所能了解到的，他们确实积极地搞了一次脱欧。不，不列颠人离开了。
yeah they say so either 409 410 as is typical with ancient history we can't absolutely pin this down we had a historian says contemporary historian says that the britons defected from roman rule and lived their own lives independent from roman laws so that does sound like a kind of Brexit. Steve Baker's fantasy. They then seem to have slightly repented it. Again, there are confusions around the sources, but it does seem that Britain's right to the emperor and say, well, everything's going wrong, please can we come back here? By this point, the empire's kind of imploding. And so the emperor writes back and says, you're on your own, you got to cope yeah um and everything goes i mean it has to be said that the uh the right you know this brexit in the fifth century doesn't entirely go according to plan
对，他们说——要么是409年，要么是410年，正如古代历史的常态一样，我们无法完全确定具体时间。我们有一位历史学家说——当时的史书记载说——不列颠人背叛了罗马的统治，过上了他们自己的生活，不再受罗马法律的约束。所以这确实听起来有点像脱欧。史蒂夫·贝克（Steve Baker）的幻想。他们随后似乎对此略有悔意。同样，史料记载有些混乱，但似乎不列颠人给皇帝写信说，嗯，一切都出毛病了，请问我们能回来吗？到了这个时候，帝国已经处於崩溃边缘。所以皇帝回信说，你们得靠自己了，你们得应付过去。是的，呃，一切都……我的意思是，必须指出的是，五世纪的这次脱欧并没有完全按照计划进行。
because basically the entire economy in place because the roman empire was what was what enabled the british economy to function but this isn't a brexit as in britain taking a unique path though is it because i mean what happened to to Britain at the end of this period, in sort of late antiquity, is surely exactly what happened to Spain or, you know, Gaul or any of the other kind of provinces of the Western Roman Empire, that they fragment. And even if we wanted to stay in the Roman Empire, there was no Roman Empire in the West anymore to be part of, right?
因为基本上整个经济体系都崩溃了，因为罗马帝国正是英国经济得以运转的基础。但这并不像英国选择独特道路意义上的脱欧，对吧？因为我的意思是，在这段时期结束时，即在古典时代晚期，英国发生的的事情，肯定与西班牙、高卢或西罗马帝国的任何其他省份发生的事情完全一样——它们分裂了。而且，即使我们想留在罗马帝国，西方也不再有什么罗马帝国可供我们成为其中的一部分了，对吧？
I think that's kind of true. But this happened, you know, the process of Rome's fall happens over several decades across the course of the 10th century. This is pretty early. And what is distinctive about it is that, you know, as the historian says,
我想这倒也是真的。但这件事发生时——罗马灭亡的过程在整个10世纪（注：此处嘉宾可能口误，通常指公元5世纪左右）的几十年间发生。这发生得很早。其独特之处在于，正如历史学家所说，
that the Britons take a decision to cast off Roman laws, Roman rule, and I guess Roman tax collectors. That's the kind of the key, the key fact. But by casting off the Roman tax collectors, they're by casting off the roman tax collectors they're also casting off the ability to to have a monetary economy and essentially coinage vanishes
不列颠人做出了抛弃罗马法律、罗马统治，以及我猜还有罗马收税员的决定。这就是那个关键的事实。但通过抛弃罗马收税员，他们同时也抛弃了维持货币经济的能力，基本上硬币消失了
for 100 200 years 300 years and it's back to barter and that is kind of the you know that is the remainers worst nightmare for what might happen might happen to Brexit Britain is that we all sit around bartering turnips and things. So, yeah, so I think that's quite an interesting one. Well, here's a quick question for you before we move on. I think the end of Rome and Britain is such a fascinating subject. We should do a whole podcast on it. But do people have at that stage any sense of British distinctiveness? Surely they don't.
长达100年、200年、300年，社会又回到了以物易物的时代。这正是留欧派对于脱欧后的英国可能发生的情况的“终极噩梦”——我们所有人坐在一起用芜菁（萝卜）之类的东西进行物物交换。所以，是的，所以我认为这是一个相当有趣的案例。好吧，在我们继续之前，我有一个简单的问题想问你。我认为罗马与不列颠的结局是一个如此迷人的课题。我们应该专门做一期播客来聊聊它。但在那个阶段，人们对不列颠的独特性有什么概念吗？他们肯定没有吧。
They don't feel that they are unique and they are separate from other provinces of the Roman Empire in a way that is not true in Spain or in Portugal or wherever. Well, it's really hard to know because we have so few, we have almost nothing written by Britons. And I think that one of the things that is distinctive about Britain, for instance, Britain is, there are no British senators. And you have Gauls who laugh, there is a British poet and a Gaulish poet laughs at the very idea of this.
他们并不觉得自己是独一无二的，并且与罗马帝国的其他省份相分离——这种感觉在西班牙、葡萄牙或其他地方并不存在。嗯，这真的很难知道，因为我们掌握的资料太少了，几乎没有什么是不列颠人自己写的。我认为英国的独特性之一在于，例如，不列颠没有罗马元老员。而高卢人有——有一位不列颠诗人和一位高卢诗人，高卢诗人在听到这种想法时甚至嘲笑它。
So you clearly have the sense, even, you know, fourth, fifth centuries, that the Britons are bumpkins, are barbarians, are backward. And I think one of the measures of what makes Britain distinctive in the Roman Empire and the way that it leaves the Roman Empire is that in Britain, we do not speak a form of Latin.
所以你显然有一种感觉，甚至在四、五世纪时，不列颠人仍然被视为乡巴佬、野蛮人和落后的人。我认为衡量英国在罗马帝国中的独特性以及它脱离罗马帝国的方式的一个标准就是，在不列颠，我们不讲某种形式的拉丁语。
You do in Spain, you do in Italy, you do in France. In Britain here, we speak a Germanic language. And so clearly something, whether it's something about the relationship of Britain as a province to the rest of the empire, or whether it's about the distinctive circumstances in which Britain ceases to be Roman, but clearly the fact that we do not speak a form of Latin, I think is the measure of just how seismic that Brexit was. So I think that's a good one. So let's put that right there. That's a tick, isn't it?
你在西班牙讲，在意大利讲，在法国讲。而在不列颠这里，我们说的是日耳曼语。所以显然有些事情——无论是关于不列颠作为罗马帝国的一个省与其他省份的关系，还是关于不列颠不再属于罗马时的独特环境——但很显然，我们不讲拉丁语这一事实，我认为就是那次脱欧具有多么震撼性影响的尺度。所以我认为这是一个很好的例子。我们就把它放在这里。这是一个符合条件的例子，对吧？
Well, not a good Brexit, but it's a powerful parallel. Next. Number three, I think, is let's flag up the reign of King John. We can all agree, bad king. Bad king, yes, I think the worst, probably. A man who really does seem to have been as bad as everyone says he was. And it's so nice when the clichés and the stereotypes turn out to be true. So his Brexit comes in two waves.
嗯，这算不上一次好的脱欧，但它是一个很有力的平行对比。接下来。第三个，我认为，让我们来关注一下约翰国王（King John）的统治。我们都可以一致认为，这是一个糟糕的国王。糟糕的国王，是的，我认为他是最糟糕的，大概吧。一个真正和人们说的一样糟糕的人。当那些陈词滥调和刻板印象被证明是真实的时候，真是太棒了。所以他的脱欧分成了两波。
So he loses the lands that he has inherited from his father on the continent in France. So in 1204, he loses the Duchy of Normandy, which of course is an inheritance from William the Conqueror originally. But he's also lost all the lands further south, the Angevin Empire. Then the following year, the Archbishop of Canterbury dies and John has his candidate. The canons at Canterbury have their candidate, and there's a kind of debate about that.
他失去了从他父亲那里继承的在欧洲大陆法国的土地。因此在1204年，他失去了诺曼底公国，这当然最初是继承自征服者威廉。但他也失去了更南边的所有土地，即安茹帝国（Angevin Empire）。接着在第二年，坎特伯雷大主教去世了，约翰推举了他自己的人选。坎特伯雷的教士们也有他们自己的人选，关于这一点产生了一场争论。
But the Pope, Innocent III, who is kind of like the uber-Pope of the Middle Ages, he's incredibly powerful, very keen on his own authority. He insists on posing his own candidate, a guy called Stephen Langton, and John refuses to allow Langton to come and claim the Archbishopric of Canterbury. So Innocent III imposes an interdict on 1208,
但是教皇英诺森三世（Innocent III）——他有点像中世纪的“超级教皇”，权力极其巨大，非常热衷于维护自己的权威——坚持强行安插他自己的人选，一个叫斯蒂芬·朗顿（Stephen Langton）的人。而约翰拒绝让朗顿来接管坎特伯雷大主教职位。因此英诺森三世在1208年实施了“禁教令”（interdict），
which basically means no services. 1209, he excommunicates John. John says, well, whatever, you know, I'm fine, let's have a hard Brexit. You know, we'll trade under wto terms whatever 12 13 there is a threat of a french invasion and suddenly john goes oh and he basically sues for term he negotiates to come back in and not only that but he basically makes a kind of gift of england to uh to innocent the third it becomes kind of papal fiefdom, which is kind of like we have a hard Brexit
这基本上意味着所有宗教仪式暂停。1209年，他将约翰开除教籍。约翰说，好吧，无所谓，你知道的，我挺好的，我们来个硬脱欧吧。你知道的，我们在世贸组织（WTO）条款下进行贸易什么的。到1213年，法国面临入侵的威胁，突然之间约翰说“哦”，他基本上开始求和，他谈判要求重返欧洲体制。不仅如此，他还基本上把英格兰作为某种“礼物”送给了英诺森三世，英格兰变成了一种教皇领地（papal fiefdom）。这有点像我们搞了一次硬脱欧，然后一切都搞砸了。
and then it all goes wrong. And basically we, not only do we rejoin the EU, but we sign up to the Euro and we become a province of Belgium or something. And we're Luxembourg. It's a huge humiliation. But, and from that point on, Innocent III is then, regards John as basically an ally
基本上我们不仅重新加入了欧盟，还签署加入了欧元区，变成了比利时或者某个国家的省份。而我们成了卢森堡。这是一个巨大的羞辱。但是，从那时起，英诺森三世就把约翰基本上视为盟友，并在与法国国王的冲突中站在约翰一边。所以在现阶段，我们迎来了脱欧派噩梦的降临，也就是超级国家，即天主教会，对吧？
and takes John's side as the French king. So at this stage, we have the arrival of the sort of Brexiteers nightmare, which is the sort of super state, which is the Catholic Church, right? So the Catholic Church is the sort of EU with knobs on, if you like. Britain is part of a supranational um body that has authority over things i mean this is the big issue that's going to come up later in our next example isn't it yes the fact that the catholic church has authority in england over and above the king yes and this has ancient roots i mean this is the pope gregory the great sends missionaries to to england um and
所以天主教会就像是带有各种附加功能的欧盟，如果你愿意这么看的话。英国是一个超国家机构的一部分，这个机构对许多事情拥有管辖权。我的意思是，这就是稍后将在我们的下一个例子中出现的大问题，对吧？是的，天主教会对英格兰拥有凌驾于国王之上的管辖权，是的。而且这有着古老的根源，我的意思是，教皇格里高利大帝（Gregory the Great）派遣传教士前往英格兰，然后
then you have uh other missionaries coming from Ireland and you have this huge debate at the Synod of Whitby. Yes. Fuck, what's the date of the Synod of Whitby? Ah, we need to know that. Dominic, have you got Wi-Fi to hand? Hold on. Then in 664, you have the Synod at Whitby,
你又有来自爱尔兰的其他传教士，并且在惠特比宗教会议（Synod of Whitby）上进行了这场大辩论。是的。见鬼，惠特比宗教会议是什么时候开的？啊，我们需要知道这个。多米尼克，你手头有无线网络吗？稍等。然后是在664年，你们召开了惠特比宗教会议，
a gathering of churchmen, and they decide, you know, are we going to go with the Celtic tradition or are we going to go with the roman tradition they go with the roman tradition and i guess that's the equivalent of joining the common market so that yeah it's the edward heath anglo-saxon edward heath and then of course and then you have the normal conquest so so in those two ways we're we're joined to a roman model of Christianity. And then thanks to William the Conqueror, we're joined to essentially a French-centred state. And John's reign sees an attempt to get rid, well, I mean, John loses the Norman lands
这是一场教士们的聚会，他们决定：我们要遵循凯尔特传统，还是遵循罗马传统？他们选择了罗马传统，我猜这相当于加入共同市场，所以——是的，这就是爱德华·希思（Edward Heath）时期的盎格鲁-撒克逊版爱德华·希思。然后当然，接下来是诺曼征服。所以通过这两种方式，我们被纳入了罗马式的基督教模式。然后由于征服者威廉，我们基本上被纳入了一个以法国为中心的国家。而约翰的统治见证了消除这种影响的尝试——好吧，我的意思是，约翰失去了诺曼底的土地，他试图摆脱罗马的控制。在大约500年的时间里，我的意思是，我们的政治基本上与法国的政治交织在一起，不是吗？我的意思是，你无法把法国和英格兰这两个故事分开来讲。但所有这些，基本上为我认为与脱欧最重大的单一平行事件做好了铺垫，那就是宗教改革，即16世纪30年代的亨利八世宗教改革。所以这就是那个例子我知道作为历史学家你不再被允许直呼其名了。
and he tries to cast off the Roman. And for 500 years or so, I mean, our politics is pretty much entangled with that of France, isn't it? I mean, you can't tell those two stories about France and England separately. But all of this basically cues up what I think is the single biggest parallel with Brexit, which is the Reformation, the Henrician Reformation in the 1530s. So this is the example that I know you're no longer allowed to mention his name as a historian.
大卫·斯塔基（David Starkey）曾经——他把亨利八世描述为“第一个脱欧派”。那是在16世纪30年代。我的意思是，这看起来太引人注目了。因为正是在16世纪30年代，你首次看到议会宣布英格兰是一个帝国（empire），英格兰是一个独立自主的实体，外国神职人员和红衣主教的权威不适用于英格兰，只有国王才是英格兰教会的最高首脑和最高统治者，英国是英国——抱歉，英格兰是独一无二的，它拥有一个特殊的地位
David Starkey has, I mean, he's described Henry VIII as the first Brexiteer. And it's in the 1530s. I mean, this seemsxiteer. And it's in the 1530s. I mean, this seems so compelling to me because it's in the 1530s that you first get Parliament declaring that England is an empire, that England is its own thing, and the authority of foreign priests and prelates will not apply to England, and that it's the king who is the supreme head and governor of England's church and that Britain is Britain sorry England is distinctive that it has an exceptional place
和一个特殊的命运。当然，后来产生的影响是——你得到了清教徒的理念，即英格兰已被上帝选中，成为更纯粹基督教形式的载体，而那些欧洲大陆迷信的天主教事物——你知道的，敌基督、罗马主教之类的一切——我的意思是，在我看来，这在后来英格兰的身份认同、苏格兰的身份认同中是如此核心。是的，因为你刚才说了英国（Britain），但我意思是，苏格兰宗教改革也是如此，是的，你知道的，他们砸毁修道院，那种难以置信的细节甚至连僧侣们种的花都要拔掉，这真的……
and an exceptional destiny and the effect later on of course you get the Puritan idea that England has been chosen by God as the sort of vehicle for a purer form of christianity and that the continental superstitious catholic stuff the you know the antichrist the bishop of rome all of this kind of thing i mean this feels to me so central in england's identity later scotland's identity yeah well scott because you said britain but i mean scott it is a scottish reformation as well yes you know they're smashing up abbey's kind of incredible detail that they even went around picking up all the flowers that the monks had planted, which really is...
这就是对细节的关注，不是吗？确实是这样。是的，我的意思是，这是最经典的例子，对吧？你买账吗？我的意思是，我认为这在英格兰的自我意识中、在英格兰的差异感中留下了如此巨大的印记。当然，这随后又因西班牙无敌舰队、火药阴谋以及所有这类事件而进一步加剧。并且我认为，我的意思是，我不认为认为英国对欧盟的独特性认知与我们16世纪的历史有着某种模糊的心理联系是一个巨大的夸大。我认为这是真的。但如果我们谈论这是否是一个平行对比，那么大卫·麦卡洛（David McCullough，注：可能口误应为Diarmaid MacCulloch），宗教改革的伟大历史学家，他的观点是，脱欧当然是英国独有的，
That's attention to detail, isn't it? It really is. Yes, I mean, this is the classic one, isn't it? And do you buy that? I mean, I think this left such a massive imprint in England's sense of itself, in England's sense of difference. And then, of course, that's compounded by the Spanish Armada
英国是唯一一个甚至在考虑离开欧盟的国家，而宗教改革显然是一场全欧洲范围的事件。亨利的宗教改革顺应了德国正在发生的事情。它将深受瑞士发生的事情的影响。它发生在——你知道的，在伊丽莎白一世统治时期，英格兰的新教徒在荷兰共和国有盟友。所以这是一项国际性的努力。因此，这或许会让情况变得有些浑浊，你觉得呢？嗯，这确实让情况变得有点扑朔迷离，不是吗？
and the gunpowder plot and all of these kinds of things. And I think, you know, I don't actually think it's a massive stretch to argue that Britain's sense of its own distinctiveness vis-à-vis the EU has some vague psychological connection to our history in the 16th century. I think that's true. But if we're talking about whether it's a parallel, so David McCullough, great historian of the Reformation, his point is that Brexit, of course, is distinctively British.
因为你说得对，宗教改革是被输入到英格兰的。我的意思是，它字面意义上是以小册子、圣经以及这类东西的形式被输入进来的。但我猜它也有着鲜明的英格兰特色，原因有二。第一，它显然是由亨利以及他跟妻子们的那些风流韵事引发的。如果不是因为安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn）之流，那么也许我们会走上一条更加法兰西化的路线。新教在英格兰并非注定会成功。但也因为在英格兰，它与君主制紧密相连，不是吗？我的意思是，因此英格兰的新教与对国家的爱国忠诚紧密结合在了一起，
Britain is the only country that's even thinking about leaving the European Union, whereas the Reformation is obviously a pan-European thing. And Henry's Reformation follows in the pan-European thing. And Henry's Reformation follows in the wake of what's been going on in Germany. It will be hugely influenced by what happens in Switzerland. It happened, you know, under Elizabeth I, the Protestants in England have allies in the Dutch Republic. So this is a kind of international effort. So perhaps whether that muddies the water, do you think? Well, it does muddy the water a bit, doesn't it?
这种情景在德国或瑞士等其他地方可能并非完全如此。而这反过来又为我们的下一个脱欧事件做好了铺垫，我认为我们可以称之为克伦威尔（Cromwell）统治下的护国公时期（Protectorate），这是由处决查理一世（Charles I）开启的。你刚才谈到了君主在宗教改革中扮演的神圣角色。但是当然，通过砍掉国王的头，英格兰的革命者实际上是在向整个欧洲竖起一个V字手势（粗俗手势）。是的。
Because you're right that the Reformation was imported into England. I mean, it was literally imported in the form of sort of pamphlets and Bibles and this sort of stuff. But I guess it also had a distinctively English cast for two reasons. One, it was obviously generated by Henry and his carry-on with his wives. Had it not been for Anne Boleyn and whatnot, then maybe we would have gone down a much more French line. There's no reason why Protestantism was inevitably going to succeed in England. But also because in England, it's bound up with the monarchy, isn't it? I mean, there's so Protestantism in England becomes bound up with a kind of patriotic loyalty to the state
而且我认为到了这个阶段，你绝对拥有了——所以我觉得亨利，你知道的，亨利显然在16世纪30年代采纳了这些宗教改革的论点，因为这对他有利，因为这能让他变得富有，能让他得到修道院的所有财产，还能让他得到他想要的妻子。但我认为，你在17世纪所拥有的、区别于16世纪的东西，是一种更深刻、真正的意识形态上的独特性感，对吧？所以像奥利弗·克伦威尔这样的人，他真的认为英格兰是被上帝选中的，它是新的耶路撒冷，英格兰拥有引领世界其他地方的独特命运，
in a way that's maybe not quite the case in Germany or in some of these other places in Switzerland or something. And that in turn cues up our next Brexit, which I think we could, the protectorate under Cromwell, which is ushered in by the execution of Charles I. And you were talking about the kind of sacral role that the monarch plays in the Reformation. But of course, by chopping off a king's head, the revolutionaries in England are really, really flicking a V sign at the whole of Europe. Yes.
或者也许是看着世界其他地方陷入堕落，而它自己则成为这种原始的乐土。我认为在前一个世纪里并没有完全达到这种程度。我猜有一种元素——我的意思是，在脱欧派中有一种声音，我猜他们曾希望脱欧会引发连锁反应，英国所做的事情将作为某种模式。我猜欧盟对脱欧的许多政策都是出于一种决心，决不允许这种情况发生。但护国公时期确实有这样一种情况：狂热分子希望英格兰能成为一盏明灯，帮助被教皇制和其他东西蒙蔽的欧洲大陆发现上帝的真理。
And I think by this stage, what you definitely have, so I think Henry, you know, Henry clearly, Henry VIII in the 1530s he picked up these sort of reformation arguments because they suited him because they would make him rich he'd be able to get all the monastery's money and because he would get you know the wife he wanted but i think what you have in the 17th century that is distinctive from the 16th century is you have a much more profound a genuine ideological sense of distinctiveness, don't you? So somebody like Oliver Cromwell, he really thinks that England has been chosen by God, that it is the new Jerusalem, that England has this sort of unique fate to lead the rest of the world,
而在这种背景下，正如我们收到的一条有趣的推文——来自帕特·罗伯茨（Pat Roberts），他谈到了英国文学中的伟大作家。他说：笛福（Defoe）留欧，斯威夫特（Swift）脱欧，拜伦（Byron）留欧，布莱克（Blake）脱欧，萨克雷（Thackeray）留欧，特罗洛普（Trollope）脱欧，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）留欧，阿诺德·贝内特（Arnold Bennett）脱欧。但在顶端，他说莎士比亚留欧，弥尔顿（Milton）脱欧。当然，弥尔顿是克伦威尔的秘书。他基本上是那个向欧洲人民讲话、解释脱欧（如果你愿意这么称呼的话）、解释正在发生的事情、为什么要这样干的人，
or maybe to let the rest of the world sink into depravity while it becomes this sort of pristine promised land. I think that's not quite there in the century before that. I guess there is an element, I mean, there's a strand among Brexiteers who, I guess, had hoped that Brexit would set up a chain reaction, that what Britain has done would serve as a kind of model. And I guess a lot of the European Union's policy towards Brexit has been a determination not to allow that to happen. But that was certainly something under the protectorate that enthusiasts for it hoped that England would serve as a kind of light to help a European continent benighted with potpourri and whatever, discover the truth of
并且绝对怀有一种希望，即这里发生的事情将有助于照亮欧洲其他地方。所以从某种程度上说，他们是同道中人。我赞同弥尔顿是脱欧派。莎士比亚，我想我能接受莎士比亚是留欧派，但他可能——我不认为他会是一个脱欧公投的人民投票者。不，我不认为莎士比亚会投票。我觉的——我的意思是，福斯塔夫（Falstaff）是个脱欧派，对吧？
God. and in that context as we've got an interesting um tweet from pat roberts he's talking about great writers in in english literature um he says defoe remains swift leave uh byron remain blake leave thackeray remain trollop leave virginia wolf remain arnold bennett leave but at the top he's got shakespeare remain and milton leave and of course, Milton is Cromwell's secretary. He's the guy who is essentially speaking to the people of Europe, explaining Brexit, if you want, explaining what's been happened, why it's been done,
是的，但福斯塔夫被拒绝了。我的意思是，亨利五世随后去入侵法国，他极其支持欧盟，他想统治欧盟。好吧，顺着这个话题，我想在我们在卷入下一波、第二轮空气（注：节目第二部分）之前，我们应该休息一下吗？是的，因为我们已经讲了
and definitely kind of hoping that what's going on here will serve to kind of light the rest of Europe. So kind of, they're a vein. I buy Milton as a leaver. Shakespeare, I suppose I'd buy Shakespeare as a remainer, but he's probably, I don't see him as a people's voter. No, I don't think Shakespeare would have voted. I think he, I think, I mean, Falstaff is a leaver, isn't he?
第一到第五部分，所以回来后我们将从第六讲到第十部分。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，旁边是汤姆·霍兰德。我们现在在谈论脱欧的平行事件。汤姆，有一件事总是让我很感兴趣，那就是关于“全球英国”（Global Britain）的言论，这在脱欧派中非常受欢迎。所以他们相信，你知道的，我们应该抬起头，不再看着佛兰德斯（Flanders）泥泞的田野，而是望向广阔的公海、新加坡、我们以前的殖民地以及所有这类事情。我猜其中的一个关键时刻——实际上可能其中最关键的时刻，就英国成为一个全球企业而言——是七年战争（Seven Years' War）。也就是从1756年到1763年，我认为这是一个你可以看到英国对自身产生略微不同的看法的时刻，作为一个世界大国的看法，你知道的，我们的边界在大西洋南部、太平洋、加拿大等等，在印度，特别是印度。你认为
Yeah, but Falstaff gets rejected. I mean, and Henry V, who then goes on and invades France he's massively in favour of the European Union he wants to run it Well on that note I think we should should we take a break before we get involved with the next, the second tranche of air? Yes because we've done
这是我们对自己看法以及对英国在世界上地位看法的一个关键时刻吗？是的。英国，我的意思是，正如你所说，当时正处于战争状态，特别是与法国。所以这是一个反复出现的主题。当然，英国在欧洲大陆确实有盟友，特别是腓特烈大帝（Frederick the Great）。而且，英国国王、
one to five so come back and we'll get from six to ten i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history uh with me dominic samrick and tom holland and we're talking about brexit parallels now one thing that's always interesting to me tom is this stuff about global
不列颠国王同时也是汉诺威选帝侯（注：此处霍兰德口误说成了加拿大选帝侯Elector of Canada）。所以，你知道的，英国并不是完全与欧洲大陆切断联系，但基本上这是第一次，对英国来说主要的战场正如你所说是在北美、加拿大、印度以及大洋上。我确实认为这确立了——这对确立“英国面向海洋”这一理念相当重要。当然，不仅是脱欧派在推动这一理念。戴高乐将军（General de Gaulle）也这样做过。我的意思是，这就是他否决英国申请加入（欧共体）的原因，即英国面向海洋。我的意思是，我认为“脱欧发生是因为留欧派（注：此处嘉宾可能口误，意指脱欧派）想要恢复大英帝国”这种想法，在留欧派对脱欧的敌意中一直是相当重要的一个组成部分。
britain which is so popular with Brexiteers. So they believe, you know, we should lift our heads from the muddy fields of Flanders and look to the wide open seas and to Singapore and our former colonies and all this kind of business. And I guess a key moment in that, probably the key moment in it, actually, in the sense of Britain being a global enterprise, is the Seven Years' War. So that's 1756 to 1763 and that's a moment I think when you can see Britain getting a slightly different sense of itself as a as a world power you know our frontiers are in the South Atlantic and the Pacific and in Canada and so on in India India particularly and do you think
是的。尽管我个人认为这并没有什么坚实的根据。我不认为，如果你看看民意调查，我不相信人们有任何——我的意思是，人们对大英帝国根本一无所知。不。
that's a key moment in our sense of ourselves and our sort of sense of Britain's place in the world? Yes. Britain is, I mean, as you say, is at war, particularly with France. So kind of a recurring theme. And, of course, Britain does have allies on the continent, notably Frederick the Great. And, of course, the King of England,
我认为这与其说是“全球英国”，不如说是“小英格兰”。他们退回到了霍比特人的洞穴里。是的，郡民们。是的，但我认为，在某种程度上——戴高乐关于英国面向海洋的论点，以及留欧派关于这一切都与帝国有关的论点——七年战争是一个至关重要的时刻，突然之间英国的主要焦点从欧洲大陆转移到了更广阔的海洋上。
King of Britain is also the Elector of Canada. So there are, you know, Britain isn't completely cut off from the continent, but basically it's the first time where the main theatres of war are for Britain, as you say, in North America, Canada, India, on the ocean. And I do think that that kind of established it, that is kind of quite important for establishing this idea
所以我觉得这是一个很好的例子。我觉得是……你读过吗？有一本很棒的关于七年战争的历史书，作者叫布伦丹·西姆斯（Brendan Sims）。如果你还记得的话，它大约有7000页厚。布伦丹·西姆斯的观点一直是——而且布伦丹·西姆斯完全不同意我们刚才所说的话——他说英国的焦点一直是欧洲，英国总是比这个帝国更关心欧洲。但他的观点——他在历史学家中是一个颇具争议的人物，而在几年前欧盟公投前夕，当他说他相信英国即将在欧盟中扮演领导角色、并将成为德国统一时期那种普鲁士式的角色时，他的信誉在我看来稍微受损了。是的，
that Britain looks to the seas. And of course, it isn't only Brexiteers who have pushed that. General de Gaulle did as well. I mean, that was the reason he gave for vetoing Britain's application, was that Britain looks to the seas. I mean, I think the idea that Brexit happened because Leavers wanted to restore the British Empire, I think has been quite an important strand
是的，那个被欧洲所有人唾弃和鄙视的欧洲局外人。嗯，也许它来到了……我认为布伦丹·西姆斯是一位非常有趣的作家，关于英国与欧洲的关系、爱尔兰与英国的关系以及整个复杂的关系网。好吧，我们会回到爱尔兰的。让我们回到爱尔兰。是的，我们会回到的，我们会回到的。
in remain hostility to Brexit. Yeah. Though I don't think it's very well founded, personally. I don't think, if you look at polls, I don't believe that people have any, I mean, people don't know anything about the British Empire at all. No.
因为我们还有另一场盛大的英法冲突要到来，不是吗？那就是拿破仑战争（Napoleonic Wars），所以这是第七点。基本上，这是一次强加给英国的脱欧，因为拿破仑征服了整个欧洲大陆，并强行推行大陆封锁体系（continental system），其中
I think it's much more Little England than global Britain. They retreat to hobbit holes. Yeah, the shire folk. Yeah, but I think that to the degree that, you know, the goalist argument that Britain looks to the seas, the Remainer argument that this is all about empire, Seven Years' War is a kind of crucial moment where suddenly Britain's main focus is moving from the continent to the broader seas. Remainer argument that this is all about empire. Seven Years' War is a kind of crucial moment where
英国商品不准进入欧洲大陆市场，英国军队无法在任何大陆登陆，当然，除了葡萄牙。是的，半岛战争（Peninsular War）。试图逆转脱欧的尝试，最终在滑铁卢达到高潮，我想是的。是的，但这有点反过来了，对吧？因为我们渴望进入欧洲，只是方式非常具有武装性。
suddenly Britain's main focus is moving from the continent to the broader sea. So I think that's a good one. I think that's... Have you read, there's a great, there's a history of the Seven Years' War by a folk called Brendan Sims. If you remember this, it's about 7,000 pages long. And Brendan Sims' argument was always, and Brendan Sims completely disagrees with what we've just said. He says Britain's focus was always Europe britain always cared more about europe than this empire but his sort of he's a controversial figure among historians and his credibility was slightly damaged for me a couple of years ago just before the eu referendum when he said that this he believed britain was about to play a leading role than you and would be the prussia of sort of german
而拿破仑想把我们挡在外面。所以在这个类比中，他就是戴高乐，我想是的。是的，我的意思是，我认为法国对英国的怀疑以及将英国排除在共同市场之外的渴望显然是一个巨大的主题。目前看来——显然我们在录制时并不知道是否会达成协议——但主要的欧洲大陆领导人、阻挠协议的似乎是马克龙总统（President Macron），
unification yes the european Yes, the European outcast, loathed and despised by everybody else in Europe. Well, maybe it came to... I think Brendan Sims is a really interesting writer, I think, on Britain's relationship to Europe and Ireland's relationship to Britain and the whole nexus. Well, we'll come back to Ireland. Let's come back to Ireland. Yeah, we will, we will.
所以这里显然有着相当深厚的根源。这就是“青蛙与蝎子”的故事，对吧？你知道的，“你为什么要蛰我”之类的，“因为这是我的本性”。我的意思是，法国人如果不这样就不是法国人了。我的意思是，如果他们只是挥挥手放行并祝我们一切顺利，那就不对了。我的意思是，那将不是他们真实的本色。而且我认为英国政府此前一直在说他们将如何登船检查法国渔船、他们正在动员海军等等，
Because we've got another big Franco, Anglo-Franco dust-up to come, haven't we? Which is, of course, the Napoleonic Wars so that that is coming in at number seven um and basically this is a brexit that is forced on britain because napoleon has conquered the whole of continental europe enforces continental system where um british goods are not allowed to enter the European markets, and British army is unable to land anywhere on the mainland, except, of course, for Portugal. Yeah, the Peninsular War. The attempt to reverse Brexit, which culminates ultimately at Waterloo, I guess. Yeah, and this is sort of going the other way, though, isn't it? Because we're keen to get into Europe, just in a very armed way.
并且有很多评论说这太荒谬了，这是在挥舞大棒、虚张声势。但显然，事实上，我认为英国相当一部分底层民意相当热衷于派遣皇家海军进入英吉利海峡对付法国的这个想法。我正想说，肯定有相当大比例投身政治的人幻想有一天他们能够动员
And Napoleon wants to keep us out. So he's de Gaulle in this analogy, I suppose. Yeah, I mean, I think that the French suspicion of Britain and the desire to exclude Britain from the common market was obviously a huge theme. And it does seem at the moment, and obviously we're recording this, we don't know whether there's going to be a deal or not, but it does seem that the main um continental leader uh blocking a deal is president macron um so there are clearly kind of quite deep roots here well this is the sort of frog and
海军去对抗法国，对吧？我的意思是，这就是你一开始投身政治的原因。那是任何看着加文·威廉姆森（Gavin Williamson）的人心中的那种黑暗焦虑。是的。但这里有一个有趣的观点，汤姆，那就是拿破仑——你知道的，他发挥了这种巨大的作用，他在英国人的想象中占据了很大的角色。而且总有一种感觉——所以，我的意思是，十进制化（decimalisation）就是一个非常好的例子，那是拿破仑式的创新，英国对此保持了冷漠，基本上持续了一个多世纪。
scorpion isn't it you know why did you why did you sting me or whatever it is because it's in my nature i mean that the french wouldn't be the French. I mean, it wouldn't be right for them to just wave it through and wish us the best. I mean, that wouldn't be, they wouldn't be true to themselves. And I think the way that the government was saying how they're going to board French fishing ships and they're mobilising the Navy and everything,
我曾经写过一篇专栏文章，标题大概是这样的：“多米尼克·桑德布鲁克回看英国失去其国家灵魂的那一刻”。没有什么好自豪的。我简直不敢相信你是基于这个来写的。那是关于我们采用十进制货币的那一刻。是的，你就是新威灵顿公爵（Duke of Wellington），你才不搞那些拿破仑式的胡闹呢。所以这是一个相当不错的例子。我的意思是，这有点——这有点颠倒过来了，因为那是我们想要加入却不被允许加入。无论如何，拿破仑战争是第七点。那么第八点是什么呢？第八点是“光辉孤立”（Splendid Isolation）。我想这并不是一个时刻，这更像是一个主题，不是吗？这是19世纪末的某种现象。英国认为自己——你知道的，我们现在非常明确地是头号国家，我们拥有帝国，帝国在英国的政治想象中占据了这种庞大的角色。
and lots of comments saying this is ridiculous, it's sabre-rattling. But obviously, actually, I think quite a substratum of opinion in Britain, quite keen on the idea of sending the Royal Navy into the channel against the French. I was about to say, there must be quite a large proportion of people who go into politics who fantasise that at some point they'll be able to mobilise
保卫印度是我们的首要任务。而对于像索尔兹伯里勋爵（Lord Salisbury，19世纪末、20世纪初的保守党首相）这样的人来说，这种认为英国应该避免国际事务的观点。
the Navy against the French, right? I mean, that's why you go into politics in the first place. That is the kind of dark anxiety of anyone watching Gavin Williamson. Yes. But there was an interesting point here, Tom, which is that Napoleon, you know, he exercised this huge sort of, he had this big role in the British imagination. And there was always a sense in So, I mean, decimalisation is a very good example of a Napoleonic innovation from which Britain stood aloof for, you know, for more than a century, basically.
海军对抗法国，对吧？我的意思是，这就是你最初参与政治的原因。这正是任何看着加文·威廉姆森的人所怀有的那种阴暗焦虑。是的。但这里有一个有趣的观点，汤姆，那就是拿破仑，你知道，他发挥了巨大的作用，他在英国人的想象中占据了重要的地位。而且一直有一种感觉，所以，我的意思是，十进制化是一个非常好的拿破仑式创新的例子，英国对此置身事外，基本上持续了一个多世纪。
I once wrote a column which had the headline, I think it said something like, Dominic Sandbrook looks back on the moment Britain lost its national soul. There's nothing to be proud of. I can't believe you're basing it on this. And it was about the moment that we adopted a decimal currency yeah you are the new duke of wellington you're not doing any
我曾经写过一篇专栏文章，标题大概是这样的，我想说的是，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克回顾了英国失去国家灵魂的那一刻。没有什么好骄傲的。真不敢相信你是基于这个来写的。这关乎我们采用十进制货币的那一刻，是的，你是新任威灵顿公爵，你不会做任何
of that napoleonic nonsense so that's quite a good one i mean that's kind of it's it's a it's um it stands on its head because that's us wanting to join and not being allowed to anyway so napoleonic wars is number seven so uh what have we got at eight so number eight is splendid isolation and i suppose this isn't a moment this is more of a sort of theme isn't it this is the sort of late 19th century uh britain sees itself as you know it's not we're now quite clearly top nation we have the empire the empire assumes this sort of colossal role in Britain's political imagination. The defence of India is our leading priority. And for people like Lord Salisbury, the Tory Prime Minister at the end of the 19th, 30th, 20th century, this sense that Britain should avoid international
那种拿破仑式的胡闹，所以这挺不错的，我的意思是，这有点像，它有点，它是，它有点颠倒过来了，因为那是我们想要加入却不被允许加入，无论如何，所以拿破仑战争是第七名，那么我们在第八名有什么呢？所以第八名是光荣孤立，我想这可不是一个时刻，这更像是一个主题，不是吗？这就是19世纪末期那种，英国视自己为，你知道，我们现在显然是头号大国，我们拥有帝国，帝国在英国的政治想象中占据了这种极其巨大的角色。保卫印度是我们的首要任务。对于像19世纪末、20世纪初的保守党首相索尔兹伯里勋爵这样的人来说，这种英国应该避免国际
entanglement, should stand apart. So for example, the Franco-Prussian War, which we talked about in our First World War podcast, that happens in 1870, 71. There's no question of Britain getting involved in it. And there's a sense, I think, quite a strong sense in late 19th century Britain that Britain is somehow above European, sort of petty European alliance politics. Of course, that was to prove not the case.
纠缠，应当保持距离。举个例子，我们在第一次世界大战的播客中讨论过的普法战争，发生在1870年到1871年。英国根本不可能介入其中。我认为，在19世纪末的英国，有一种非常强烈的看法，即英国某种程度上超然于欧洲那些琐碎的联盟政治之上。当然，事实证明并非如此。
But I think that, again, psychologically, has left a deep imprint in that people still this sort of isolationism yeah it's kind of fogging the channel continent cut off continent cut off exactly yes exactly and I think um you know we saw how wrong that was with the first world war when you know we did the very opposite of a brexit we piled in but I think imaginatively Tom that's left a a very long legacy don't you well isn't it the case that almost invariably, where you think there's a long historical tradition, it turns out to have been invented by the Victorians?
但我觉得，在心理上，这再次留下了深刻的烙印，人们依然存在这种孤立主义情绪，是的，这就像是一种海峡迷雾，把大陆隔绝开来，大陆被隔绝了，完全正确，是的，正是如此。我认为，嗯，你知道的，我们通过第一次世界大战看到了这种想法是多么错误，当时我们并没有选择脱欧，而是全力卷入。但我认为，从想象力的角度来看，汤姆，这留下了一个非常长久的遗产，不是吗？好吧，几乎毫无疑问，每当你以为存在一个悠久的历史传统时，结果往往都是由维多利亚时代人发明的，难道不是吗？
And it may be that everything that we've been talking about, this kind of sense of Britain being an island and separate and distinct and everything that animated the Brexit vote, is basically a legacy of that late Victorian sense of itself when we really were kind of isolated because we had the Navy. So nobody could cross the sea without our permission. And our investments were all global. And I think that perhaps the cast of thought,
也许我们一直在谈论的一切，这种英国是一个岛屿、独立且与众不同的感觉，以及所有推动脱欧投票的因素，基本上都是晚期维多利亚时代自我意识的遗产。那时我们确实因拥有海军而处于某种孤立状态。因此，未经我们的许可，没有人能横渡大海。而且我们的投资遍布全球。我想，这种思维方式，
maybe that is something that lingers. Don't know. Yeah, no, I think it does. I think it's that sort of sense, isn't it, that there's sort of people in Buenos Aires playing rugby and talking about beef, and that Britain has become this much more global enterprise, and that the politics of Belgium and Luxembourg and whatnot
也许这是一种挥之不去的东西。不知道。是的，不，我认为确实如此。我认为这就是那种感觉，不是吗？就好比布宜诺斯艾利斯的人们在打橄榄球、谈论牛肉，而英国已经成为了一个更加全球化的企业，相比之下，比利时和卢森堡之类的政治，
seems so small-scale. Although, I mean, Britain acts as a guarantor for Belgium, right? Yeah, of course. And Disraeli is negotiating with Bismarck. So Britain isn't... I mean, we're not as gloriously isolated as perhaps the myth would have it. The glorious isolation is more... It's a sort of...
显得如此小规模。尽管我的意思是，英国充当了比利时的担保人，对吧？是的，当然。迪斯雷利正在与俾斯麦谈判。所以英国并不是……我的意思是，我们并不像神话所描绘的那样享有无上的孤立。这种光荣孤立更多的是……它是一种……
It's an aspiration, I think, as much as a reality, yeah. And, you know, we were talking about the historian Brendan Sims. He would say, this is all rubbish and actually Britain was always profoundly entangled with European politics. I mean, that's the fascination of this subject, isn't it? It's actually quite apart from the sort of the ranting and raving of the various partisans.
它既是一种渴望，也是一种现实，是的。而且，你知道的，我们之前谈到过历史学家布伦丹·西姆斯。他会说，这些都是胡扯，实际上英国一直与欧洲政治有着深度的纠缠。我的意思是，这就是这个主题的迷人之处，不是吗？它实际上完全不同于各种党派的狂热叫嚣。
It's such a fascinating subject because rather like, I think rather like Russia, Britain has always been in this position where it is clearly part of the continental system and part of Europe, and yet at the same time feels itself pulled away from it. And that will never be resolved. And the effect of all these historical episodes is kind of double ratcheted up, because in the present, there is this sense, and then it gets enhanced and turbocharged by kind of distorted myths and memories of how the past had operated.
这是一个如此迷人的主题，因为就像俄罗斯一样，英国一直处在这样一个位置：它显然是大陆系统和欧洲的一部分，然而与此同时，它又觉得自己被拉扯着想要离开。这一点永远不会得到解决。所有这些历史事件的影响都得到了双重加剧，因为在当下，存在着这种感觉，然后它被对过去运作方式的歪曲神话和记忆所放大并注入了强心剂。
On both sides, though, on both sides. So the Brexiteers think that we've always been different and Remainers say, oh, no, you've always been completely European. You had European monarchs and blah, blah, blah. And they both, as you say, they sort of double down on the sort of historical myth making. And talking of historical myth making, we now come to number nine. This is slightly different and is prompted by a tweet from Pat Roberts, who says the ERG versus Theresa May. So the ERG, the kind of the Spartan, the Spartans, the hardcore Brexiteers, versus Theresa May is de Valera versus Michael Collins.
不过，双方都是如此，双方都是。因此，脱欧派认为我们一直与众不同，而留欧派则说，哦，不，你们一直都是彻底的欧洲人。你们有欧洲君主，等等等等。正如你所说，他们都在历史神话的构建上变本加厉。说到历史神话的构建，我们现在来到第九个。这稍有不同，是由帕特·罗伯茨的一条推文引发的，他说的是欧洲研究小组（ERG）对阵特雷莎·梅。因此，ERG，也就是那种斯巴达式的、强硬的脱欧派，对阵特雷莎·梅，就像是德瓦莱拉对阵迈克尔·柯林斯。
Are you really leaving if you're still taking the oath? So that's a reference to um not Britain leaving Europe but Ireland leaving the United Kingdom and yeah I think that is a kind of interesting one because um Ireland leaving the United Kingdom it was leaving a kind of single market um yes leaving a union of nations um everyone said this will be economically disastrous went ahead anyway did turn out to be economically difficult and one of the things that that was difficult for ireland was that it basically remained within the tract of beam of the british economy yes really right the way up until joining the common market um and i guess that the
如果你还在宣誓，你真的算是在离开吗？所以这指的是，嗯，不是英国离开欧洲，而是爱尔兰离开联合王国。是的，我认为这是一个挺有意思的例子，因为嗯，爱尔兰离开联合王国，它其实是离开了一个单一市场，是的，离开了一个国家联盟。当时所有人都说这会在经济上造成灾难，但还是继续进行了，结果确实在经济上变得很艰难。对爱尔兰来说比较艰难的事情之一，是它基本上仍然留在了英国经济的引力场范围内。是的，确实如此，一直持续到加入共同市场为止。我猜，那个
remain argument is that that will be the fate of Britain that we may formally leave the European Union but our economy will not be strong enough to escape the tractor beam so effectively we will be dependent but without any say and so that was the argument against Irish independence. Well that is the argument but also there's another dimension to it Tom which is I think that people often talk about Britain rejoining the EU. They sort of say, well, you know, you'll realise your mistake, or we'll realise our mistake, and we will go back. But of course, very quickly in Ireland, I mean, there had been the case when somebody secedes from a union or becomes independent. Once the decision is made, it becomes the status quo incredibly quickly and it becomes very, very hard to row back. So if you'd said to somebody in Ireland in 1951, let's say, do you not regret it now? Do you think you should rejoin the United Kingdom?
留欧派的论点是，这将是英国的命运，我们可能在形式上离开了欧盟，但我们的经济不够强大，无法摆脱引力场，所以实际上我们仍将处于依附地位，却没有任何发言权。这就是反对爱尔兰独立的论点。嗯，这确实是个论点，但汤姆，这里还有另一个层面，那就是我认为人们经常谈论英国重新加入欧盟。他们会说，嗯，你知道的，你们会意识到自己的错误，或者我们会意识到自己的错误，然后我们就会回去。但当然，在爱尔兰，这种情况非常快就发生了——当某个地方从一个联盟中分离或独立时，一旦做出决定，它就会以极其惊人的速度成为现状，并且变得非常非常难以倒退。所以，如果你在1951年左右对爱尔兰人说，比方说，你们现在不后悔吗？你们觉得应该重新加入联合王国吗？
I mean, they would have laughed at you. It seemed such a ludicrous suggestion. It would have seemed impossible to rejoin the UK. Although I suppose the difference is that there's a kind of legacy of overt imperialism. Yes. That has poisoned relations between, I suppose, particularly England and Ireland for centuries and centuries. And that hasn't been the case with Europe. No, it hasn't. But of course, if you're a very keen Brexiteer, you would say,
我的意思是，他们会嘲笑你的。这看起来是一个荒谬的建议。重新加入英国似乎是不可能的。尽管我想区别在于，这里有一种公开的帝国主义遗产。是的。我认为这几个世纪以来一直毒化了特别是英格兰和爱尔兰之间的关系。而这在欧洲并不是这样。不，确实不是。但是，如果你是一个非常狂热的脱欧派，你会说，
you know, the Irish look to their history and they see a story of separateness and distinctiveness that has finally been vindicated or has finally been, you know, finally sort of redeemed the suffering of the past. And a Brexiteer would say, well, they would similarly point to a distinctive history and they would say this is merely the culmination of that long history. Of course, not a history that has a sort of sense of suffering in it in the same way. But I think, isn't this what countries always do when they leave unions or when they become independent? They then create a nationalist sort of historiography of which this is merely the crowning glory. Yes. But I guess, I mean, just to reiterate,
你知道的，爱尔兰人回顾他们的历史，看到的是一个独立和独特的故事，这个故事最终得到了证实，或者说最终，你知道的，最终某种程度上救赎了过去的苦难。而脱欧派会说，他们同样会指出一段独特历史，并会说这不过是那段悠久历史的高潮。当然，这段历史并没有包含那种同样带有苦难感的内容。但我想，这不正是国家在离开联盟或获得独立时一贯的做法吗？它们随后创造了一种民族主义的历史叙事，而这一切不过是其中的无上荣耀。是的。不过我想，再次重申一下，
I think that the difference is that it is hard for Brexiteers, although maybe some of the more extreme However, lurking behind all of that, the attitude towards the continent is perhaps the most recent Brexit. So what do we have at number 10, Dominic? Well, I think this is a very, yeah, this is the funnest Brexit, which is Dunkirk. So Dunkirk is a literal Brexit.
我认为区别在于，对于脱欧派来说这很难，尽管也许一些更极端的……然而，潜藏在这一切背后的，是对欧洲大陆的态度，这也许是最新的脱欧。那么，多米尼克，我们在第十个话题里有什么？嗯，我觉得这是一个非常，是的，这是最有趣的脱欧，也就是敦刻尔克。所以敦刻尔克是一个字面意义上的脱欧。
I mean, we literally leave European soil. Of course, again, like all Brexits, it's kind of muddy because we take some French and some Belgian soldiers with us. We rely very much on the French and the Belgians to kind of shield our retreat. And there's that, you know, all that famous stuff about George VI saying to Churchill that he feels much better after Dunkirk because we no longer have any allies that we have to be nice to. But of course we do because we've got all the poles flying. Yeah. There's sort of the famous cartoon in the evening standard of the Tommy standing on the cliffs, shaking his fist at the clouds and saying, very well then alone.
我的意思是，我们字面意义上离开了欧洲大陆的土地。当然，再次像所有脱欧一样，情况有点含糊不清，因为我们带走了一些法国和比利时的士兵。我们非常依赖法国人和比利时人来掩护我们的撤退。而且你知道的，所有那些著名的关于乔治六世对丘吉尔说的话，说他在敦刻尔克之后感觉好多了，因为我们不再有任何必须对他们客气的盟友了。但我们当然还是有，因为我们有许多波兰人飞行员。是的。在《旗帜晚报》上有一幅著名的漫画，画着一个汤米站在悬崖上，对着云层挥舞着拳头，说：“很好，那就孤军奋战吧。”
And obviously Dunkirk, as a Brexit, has played a massive role in our sense of ourselves right so clearly the mythology of it has been important and the readiness of certain tory mps to vote the second world war whenever the topic of brexit comes up very inaptly named has been and nigel thrush has been a kind of running um running feature of the the Brexit debate it's not remotely accurate is it because the European Union can in no way be compared to Nazi Germany I mean no although of course people have tried I think there's a isn't there a book by um Andrew Roberts a novel called the Archen Memorandum which is it's even got the kind of
很显然，敦刻尔克作为一种脱欧，在我们的自我认知中扮演了巨大的角色。没错，所以它的神话显然一直很重要，而且某些保守党议员在每次提到脱欧话题时，总是极其不合时宜地投票支持第二次世界大战，奈杰尔·瑟什也将这变成了一种贯穿脱欧辩论的长期特征。这完全不准确，不是吗？因为欧盟在任何方面都不能与纳粹德国相比。我的意思是，不，尽管当然有人试图这样做。我想，安德鲁·罗伯茨写过一本书，里面不是有一部小说叫《阿肯备忘录》（The Archen Memorandum）吗？那本书甚至还有那种……
gothic script of the title. It's done in a sort of Germanic script. I think it was published in the mid 1990s. And that's about, I think it's a plot for a fourth Reich or something like that. I mean, not even the most vituperative Brexiteer. I can absolutely see that the mythology of it, very well alone, all that kind of stuff. Yeah. We won the Second World War, blah, blah. I mean, that is clearly a crucial part of the mythology of it very well alone all that kind of stuff yeah we won the second world war blah blah i mean that's that is clearly crucial part of the the kind of emotional swirl as a parallel it's a terrible parallel well i mean all these parallels i mean parallels by their nature of course but i think this is a particularly a particularly terrible parallel but i think
哥特式的书名字体。它是用一种日耳曼式的字体制作的。我想它是在20世纪90年代中期出版的。那是关于什么的，我想是一个关于第四帝国或类似事物的阴谋。我的意思是，即使是最刻薄的脱欧派……我完全能理解它的神话色彩，“很好，那就孤军奋战吧”，所有这些类似的东西。是的。我们赢得了第二次世界大战，等等等等。我的意思是，这显然是其神话中至关重要的一部分……很好，那就孤军奋战吧，所有这些类似的东西，是的，我们赢得了第二次世界大战，等等等等。我的意思是，那显然是那种情感漩涡中至关重要的一部分。作为一种类比，这是一个糟糕的类比。嗯，我的意思是，所有这些类比，类比本身当然都有局限性，但我认为这是一个特别糟糕的类比，不过我认为……
this is i mean i think if i was picking two that mattered okay so we've we've gone through the 10 we've gone through the 10 let's should we pick the 10. Let's, should we pick out our top three? Right, okay. Okay, and we're not saying the most accurate because none of them are accurate. I mean, these are all incredibly tendentious parallels. I mean, that's the nature of these parallels. Let's say... I've already done this podcast. Yes, absolutely. But let's say the ones that hold up the most interesting mirror. Okay, so if I was picking, I mean, your first one, which a lot of people would have thought was sort of very spurious,
这就是，我的意思是，如果让我挑选两个最重要的……好了，我们已经过完了这十个，我们已经过完了这十个，我们应该把这十个挑出来吗？让我们，我们应该选出我们的前三名吗？好吧，好的。好的，我们并不是说最准确的，因为它们都不准确。我的意思是，这些全都是极其带有倾向性的类比。我的意思是，这就是这些类比的本质。比方说……我已经做过这个播客了。是的，绝对的。但比方说那些呈现出最有趣镜像的。好吧，如果我要选的话，我的意思是，你的第一个，很多人会认为是非常虚假的，
which is the Dogland one. I mean, you can argue that really matters, right? I think it's the most important. I think it's the single most important. Britain as an island. Yeah, the geography is fundamental. I would include that. I would include,
也就是多格兰的那一个。我的意思是，你可以辩称这真的很重要，对吧？我认为这是最重要的。我认为这是最重要的一点。英国作为一个岛屿。是的，地理是根本。我会把这个算进去。我会把，
I would personally definitely include the Reformation. Would you include the Reformation? Definitely. This is disappointing. Oh. Reformation came in, you were rejecting a whole corpus of laws and assumptions and proprieties, and you were definitely setting yourself at odds with the major powers on the continent. So I think that, yeah, I think that's probably the least tendentious parallel of the lot. You see, if I was picking, I mean, it's not a very successful parallel, as we've said, but in terms of mattering, I dunkirk and the second world war i think you get you know the second world war you don't get brexit i mean obviously you don't because the history is
我个人绝对会把宗教改革算进去。你会把宗教改革算进去吗？绝对会。这挺令人失望的。哦。宗教改革到来时，你拒绝了整套法律、假设和礼仪，你无疑让自己与欧洲大陆的主要强国对立起来。所以我认为，是的，我认为这可能是所有类比中最不具倾向性的一组了。你看，如果我来选，我的意思是，正如我们所说，这不是一个很成功的类比，但就重要性而言，敦刻尔克和第二次世界大战，我认为你懂的……没有第二次世界大战，就不会有脱欧。我的意思是，显然不会，因为历史是……
different but the second world war place that sort of dad's army dam busters view of britain and indeed of europe is so huge in people's sense of their own national identity. And I think it matters so much that Britain is the one major European country that goes through both world wars without being occupied and without being defeated. And it means the way we tell the story of the 20th century in which the EU is created is very different from how every other European country tells that story. Don't you think Dunkirk matters? Okay, if we, based on the fact that we're talking about the most interesting mirror, I will, I'll grant you that. I do think it's played a crucial role in...
不同的，但第二次世界大战所带来的那种“爸爸的军队”、“破坝者”式的英国乃至欧洲视角，在人们的民族身份认同感中占据着如此巨大的分量。而且我认为它如此重要，因为英国是唯一一个经历两次世界大战而没有被占领、没有被击败的主要欧洲国家。这意味着我们讲述20世纪故事的方式——欧盟正是在这个世纪创建的——与世界上其他任何欧洲国家讲述这个故事的方式截然不同。难道你不认为敦刻尔克很重要吗？好吧，如果我们基于我们正在讨论的是最有趣的镜像这一事实，我承认这一点。我确实认为它发挥了至关重要的作用……
Are you gutted we didn't choose King John? Quite disappointed. Yeah, quite disappointed. Well, you see, there are a number of, there are a number on these that, if you're expecting the worst, and to reiterate, we don't know whether people, even as we speak, are squabbling over turnips out on the streets. So if that's the case, if there has been no deal and it's all gone disastrously wrong and planes are dropping from the air, then the Roman Brexit, that might be a good comparison. And the John one would be interesting in terms of you know
你是不是对我们没选约翰王感到很沮丧？相当失望。是的，相当失望。你看，这里有许多，这里有许多类似的例子，如果你预期最坏的情况，再次重申，我们甚至不知道在此时此刻人们是否正在街头为萝卜争吵不休。所以如果是这样的话，如果没有达成协议，一切都惨遭失败，飞机从天上掉下来，那么“罗马脱欧”可能会是一个很好的比较。而且约翰王的那个例子在某种程度上也很有趣，如果你知道……
if it goes spectacularly wrong will we perhaps have to go back cap in hand um the Irish one I think is also interesting that even if that happens probably not let me ask you a question Tom about the Roman Brexit uh which I find so fascinating when the Romans left I mean did they leave did people who left surely I mean the number of people who actually physically left must have been pretty small. increasingly coming across the North Sea. So there are large quantities of forces in Britain. And as the centre implodes on the continent, so it becomes incredibly appealing for Roman commanders in Britain to have a crack at becoming emperor. And so they increasingly strip the province of its garrisons,
如果事情错得离谱，我们是否可能不得不卑躬屈膝地回去？爱尔兰的那个例子我也觉得很有趣，即使那样发生了，可能也不会。汤姆，我想问你一个关于“罗马脱欧”的问题，我觉得它太迷人了。当罗马人离开时，我的意思是，他们真的离开了吗？那些离开的人，毫无疑问，实际物理离开的人数一定相当少。越来越多的势力穿过北海。所以在英国有大量的军队。随着大陆中心的崩溃，在英国的罗马指挥官们想要尝试成为皇帝，这就变得极具吸引力。因此，他们越来越多地撤走该省的驻军，
take them across the Channel. They invariably lose. So ultimately what's happened by the beginning of the 5th century is that you no longer have any garrisons take them across the channel. They invariably lose. So ultimately what's happened by the beginning of the fifth century is that you no longer have any garrisons, really. You don't really have any Roman forces left. And yet the Britons have still been required to pay the taxes. So I think that that's essentially what precipitates the kind of we're Brexiting. Their EU budget contributions are not seeing a decent return yeah exactly exactly so um so yeah interest but i agree i totally agree about you that we must do
把他们带过海峡。他们总是会失败。所以最终到公元5世纪初发生的事情是，你基本上不再有任何驻军把他们带过海峡了。他们总是会失败。所以最终到公元5世纪初发生的事情是，你基本上不再有任何驻军了。你真的没有任何罗马军队留下了。然而，布列松人仍然被要求纳税。所以我想这本质上就是催生了那种“我们要脱欧”情绪的原因。他们对欧盟预算的贡献没有看到像样的回报，是的，完全正确，完全正确。所以，嗯，是的，有趣，但我完全同意你关于我们必须……
a podcast on the end of roman britain i think it would be yeah very very interesting one of our new year's resolutions yes uh anyway so um i hope you've enjoyed that. Wishing you a very happy new year and as good a Brexit as we can hope. And I hope everything in 2021 is better than it's been in 2020. Thanks very much for listening. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
做一期关于罗马不列颠结束的播客，我觉得那会非常非常有趣。这是我们新年愿望之一。是的，无论如何，嗯……希望你们喜欢这一期。祝大家新年快乐，并祝我们能迎来一个尽可能好的脱欧结果。我希望2021年的一切都比2020年更好。非常感谢收听。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取专属单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。